[موسيقى]
قبل أن أعمل في مجال الخدمات اللوجستية
لقد تركت هذه الوظيفة لأنني فعلت
لقد سئمت وأردت العمل
بالنسبة لي لأفعل ما يرضي في بلدي
شاحنة صغيرة
اليوم أكسب نصف ما
لقد فزت من قبل ولكن لدي ابتسامة
كل صباح عندما استيقظ
وهذا يستحق كل الذهب في العالم
لينة جدا الساعة لا داعي للقلق
التوضيح هو سياق كامل
اسمي هو تييري عرق وابتسام في
باريس وإيل دو فرانس
عملائي هم أساسًا
تقديم الطعام لتجارة المواد الغذائية
تقديم الطعام لبائعي الأسماك وماذا أنا
أفعل في الواقع أنا أتحرك مع بلدي
شاحنة أذهب أمام منزلهم وأنا
استرداد سكاكينهم الحادة
لذلك أعمل على موادهم و
أنا أعيدهم
إذا قررت القيام بذلك في
الشاحنة لها الجانب
المتجول لا تكون ثابتة السلطة لي
نزهة طوال اليوم حتى الجميلة
مناطق باريس
لقد اشتريت الشاحنة التي كانوا عليها
شبه فارغة كانت هناك فقط الخطط
عمل
واشتريت الآلات شيئًا فشيئًا
صغير في الواقع ألتقي بجميع أنواع
السكين بشكل عام هناك حوالي عشرة واحد
خمسة عشر سكين مختلفة الشكل
أو مواد مختلفة
أستخدم آلات مختلفة اعتمادًا على
المشاكل التي أدركتها في البداية
فقط لجعل التوقيع وبعد ذلك
ثم لجعل المقص الذي
ثم لأدوات الحدائق و
شيئا فشيئا أنا أجهزهم
[موسيقى]
لتكون طاحونة عليك أن تكون حذرا
عليك أن تحب ما نفعله
يعهد بالمواد التي تكلف في بعض الأحيان
مكلف للغاية لذا عليك إعادته بشكل جيد
دولة في حالة أفضل مما نحن عليه
اعطيها
كل محترف أو فرد لديه
المواد التي قطعته وهناك
تعبت من رمي هناك مثل الناس
أنا هنا لإصلاح
إعطاء حياة ثانية للأشياء و
هذا مهم أشعر بأنني مفيد